es una demanda civil Pero hay otros
procesos legales en curso aumentan las
posibilidades de cargos penales contra
Donald Trump
hoy ha sido un día tétrico para Donald
Trump y su familia primero la demanda
por la vía civil del estado de New York
a los acusándolo de un
fraude empresarial en gran escala Esto
es algo que va a paralizar los la
compañía de Trump sus negocios y va a
imponerle que hayan personas que lo
sustituyan a ellos a la familia como
directores de esas empresas se está
pidiendo una multa de 250 millones de
dólares por alegatos de que las empresas
Trump defraudaron a los ciudadanos de
Nueva York valorizando sus propiedades
mayor de lo que en realidad valían para
conseguir préstamos y después declarando
un a esas mismas propiedades con un
valor mucho menor cuando llegaron el
momento de pagar los impuestos eso es la
vida civil hace solamente unos minutos
la de apelaciones de Atlanta
virós la orden la de la jueza Canon que
prohibía el departamento de justicia de
proceder con la investigación criminal
utilizando los documentos que
encontraron enrolago que fueron mal
llevados de la Casa Blanca eso permite
al departamento de justicia de proceder
con la investigación criminal en contra
de Donald Trump Claridad es un tema que
vamos a abordar más adelante vamos a
concentrarnos entonces en esta demanda
civil de la fiscal general Leticia James
que nos dice el hecho de que sea ella la
que haya Interpuesto esta demanda y no
Los afectados que son los bancos y las
aseguradoras
ella considera que esto ha sido un
fraude como en este país todo lo que sea
de cuestión de seguros de pólizas de
seguros de se considera un delito
federal un delito Y también estatal en
el estado de Nueva York entonces lo que
se ha estado alegando por la fiscal de
Nueva York es que las empresas Trump que
están basadas en Nueva York la forma que
hicieron sus negocios fueron negocios de
que de trampa que estaban haciendo
trampa para conseguir beneficios para
los directores de esas empresas por eso
no solamente se ha nombrado al ex
presidente Donald Trump sino también a
sus hijos y algunos de los otros
directores de estas empresas Trump
empresas que son en realidad pequeñas si
las comparamos con el volumen de sus
negocios la parte de la dirigencia es
pequeña y por lo tanto afectan
directamente en forma personal aquellas
personas que tenían conocimiento del
fraude que estaba cometiendo lo que se
ha dicho aquí Hoy es que el propio
presidente Trump firmaba y aprobaba esos
ficticios que hacen que declaraban
falsos valores a sus negocios en sus
negocios y bien como se lo mencionaba
hace unos momentos una corte de
apelaciones permitió al departamento de
Justicia reanudar la revisión de los
documentos incautados de la casa del ex
presidente Donald Trump en Florida y que
son clasificados como ultrasecretos
ahora esta suspensión ahora había sido
impuesta por la jueza Federal Aylin
Canon a la espera de que el perito
independiente que ya designó reymond
dirty los revisará por separado ahora
esta medida le da un impulso a la
investigación sobre el manejo de estos
documentos señor peñalver que implica
este nuevo revés para Trump
peligrosísimo peligrosísimo porque el
hecho de que se hayan llevado estos
documentos tan secretos de la Casa
Blanca eso en sí es un delito la gran
pregunta es por qué se llevaron esos
documentos porque no solamente se los
llevó sino que insistió en retener
control de esos documentos después de
que el departamento de Justicia se los
pidió a las buenas después de que una
corte Federal le mandara una orden
judicial para que los entregara porque
sus abogados falsificaron una
declaración jurada diciendo de que todos
los documentos ya se habían llevado de
Manolo lago y después cuando vino la el
allanamiento del 8 del 8 de agosto pues
se encontraron cientos de documentos que
todavía permanecían y algunos de ellos
En el buró personal del ex presidente
Trump en una gaveta donde estaban
también sus pasaportes y pertenencias
más más personales por lo tanto eso
indica una directa conocimiento directo
del expresidente con este delito que se
acusa que se daba cometiendo algo que lo
implica él directamente que podíamos ver
la presentación de un de cargoso de
penales de cargos criminales